If you think Wawa is a store,
you won't mind prison.
Yeah, that's actually been
our motto our whole-
But if you've been having
a personal chef,
like an omelet chef
every morning.
If you think Wawa's a store,
you're just correct.
And you've just have traveled
this great land.
If prison food is like
Wawa food,
well then sign this guy up.
I'm gonna shoot this guy
in the head right now.
What do you want me to do?
Off DJ Lou?
Yeah, I'll do it on camera.
I'll do it on camera.
You tell me I get Wawa every day
and I get to talk to the cause.
I get to write my slam poems.
But you know somewhere there's
a lab for all the Wa food.
And there's a moment where one
of the heads of the company
is trying the new hamburger.
He'll be like this is fantastic.
You know there's a massive
process for every product.
Yeah absolutely and they do
little test tube drops.
Now that tastes like ranch.
I did a commercial for Doritos.
It was that Super Bowl
commercial thing
that everyone does every year.
Do you know about ...
I remember when you did that, it
was you and Matt McCarthy right?
Yeah, it was Doritos beer
is the spot that we won with.
We didn't win
the whole thing.
So we got to go and they were
giving us a tour of Frito
Lay Doritos
employees and stuff.
And one guy was like yeah
we can make a Dorito
that tastes like anything.
I was like what do you mean.
And he was like
fresh mown grass.
I was like that's
pretty interesting.
And he was like we made one
that tastes like fear.
What?
Because fear is like
a pheromone you release.
We made a chip
that tastes like fear.
And then he goes we made one
that tastes like mother.
What?
That is like what do you mean.
Terrifying.
He goes it tastes like the
sensation of being a child
with your mother, that pheromone
that your mom releases
when she's breast feeding.
They were like would
that be a popular flavor.
Just breast milk, they just have
a bunch of ladies with udders
sitting there getting pumped.
They go mother's
almost ready for tasting.
I don't mind so much, I read my
red book and just sit here.
Oh you just got out
of the milking station.
They could do a combo flavor
that makes you feel like
you're afraid of your mother.
Oh, that's what it is, yeah.
Or they could just have
my mom raise you
and you could just live
in constant fear of her.
Is that why you know
what gen pop is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, my mom used
only prison terms
when she was breaking me in.
She goes all right,
time for the yard.
That's a cold hose Trish.
Your mom didn't raise you
she broke you in.
She broke me,
she made me obedient.
Watch this.
That's so funny.
Now that's ranch.
God gives me the babies
and I sort em out.
She goes well, if he's
a little bit of a stickler.
Is this a real headline?
Bill Cosby to get first
serving of Jello in jail
Thursday, will have access
to TV and email.
I tell you what, not a bad life.
He finally has something
to email people.
Isn't it weird that you could
rape just so many people
and then the day
you get to jail,
he's just like who's gonna
set up the wi-fi?
Yeah.
Why does he have mail
and email and ...
Yeah, email and TV? That's like
a sustainable ...
he has such minimal time
left anyway.
That he doesn't need
more than those things.
And I bet at 81 years old
he's happy someone else
is controlling the TV.
He's that age where he's like
I don't know
how to shift the channel.
I'm afraid of the Internet
you see.
Could someone read me
my Internet mail.
Are the demons in the box,
the boopin and the pipin.
Do you remember when Bill Hicks
was really mad that
Jay Leno
did a Doritos commercial?
The Joey Lawrence thing where
he says he kills himself, yeah.
What?
Yeah, he says you're off
the artistic roll call
when he did the Doritos, yeah
Bill Hicks, that's what
he says about Jay Leno.
That's how much the world
has changed
where there's literally nobody
not doing a Doritos commercial.
And that was a big thing,
like he sold out.
He was furious.
Yeah about Jay Leno
doing a Doritos commercial.
I would love to do it,
I'll do it for fear and mommy.
I'll fucking push
whatever chip they want.
So most of your listeners
listen on Sirius radio.
But you like to do
a lot of visuals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No that's basically
our number one note
from our executive producer is
we need to stop watching videos.
To which we say shut up.
We said go to @thebonfire,
him or Christine is non-stop
during the show putting up
these companion pieces
to see what we're talking about.
'Cause a lot of people listen
on demand or steal it
and we're fine with both.
And then they can sync up
with our Twitter
and see all the pictures
and videos.
Remember when Netflix was like
steal it, we don't care.
Do they still feel that way?
Oh about the discs, that's when
they used to mail you the DVD's.
Yeah, I still have one.
What do you have?
What's the late fee on that?
Well remember when you used
to go to ...
what was the video store?
Blockbuster?
Blockbuster.
You would forget to return it
and they would charge you
like $75.
And that's why they went
bankrupt because everyone,
the second they had
another option
they were like fuck you
for screwing me-
Spiteful.
So many times.
I spent a night in jail.
I spent a night
in jail for that.
What?
In gen pop?
For not ... gen pop.
C-Block, good call,
that's how he learned it,
in gen pop for sure.
Frozen bologna sandwich
the whole nine.
Why's that?
For not returning video tapes
and then this particular
video store,
it wasn't Blockbuster
it was a mom-and-pop store.
That's where you had
to go to
Hollywood Video?
No, it was one of the ones
where you go to get ...
there were some saloon doors
you could blow open.
Oh adult videos.
Adult films, took them,
never returned them.
That guy, didn't know this,
he would take people to court
and you really wouldn't ...
I wouldn't be paying attention
at like 18 years old for court
documents coming to my house.
And you'd find out he took you
to court and you lost
because you didn't show up.
And you have a bench warrant
for not showing up in court.
That's cra-
When you get pulled over
for whatever,
your tail light's out
or some nonsense,
the cop runs your thing and you
have a warrant for your arrest
and they take you in.
So you went to a night of jail.
Do you remember what movies?
Something-
Prison lesbians I hope.
You know what I think it was.
I think I used to get
these videos, they were weird.
They were like home videos
that would be like Mardi Gras
or these weird festivals
around the country
where they would have people ...
it was like
Girls Gone Wild but dirtier.
Girls Gone Wild was
more of the showing tits-
Girls Gone Very Wild.
Yeah, Girls Gone
Extraordinarily Wild.
Nuts, these girls
have gone nuts.
Girls Gone Bat Shit.
I've told this story,
I'm embarrassed how many times
I've told this story to you
Jay, is that when
I was super Christian,
back when you knew me.
When you first met me.
And this is what
Crashing is about,
that guy trying to be in comedy.
You and I walked from
the cellar to the corner
and I'll never forget it,
you go let me see
that Club magazine.
The guy give you Club-
Club.
Which is just stills of porn.
It's not like a studio.
It's not a nude magazine,
it is a hard core pornography.
No, it's like here's
some butt holes.
And you flipped through it,
for what I don't know,
and then handed it back.
Yeah, I got it.
And I was there like I am
so ashamed
I've ever masturbated
and this guy's like maybe
I'll take some mental pics
for later.
Dude I love that.
Jay goes through it-
Or it didn't do it for you.
Like the Economist.
You go hm, all right,
that's going on there.
Have you ever asked
for a magazine,
any magazine, flipped through it
and given it back.
No.
Club magazine, you're like yeah
that's about right.
Sometimes
they give you a free DVD.
A young Samantha Fox
was a part of Club.
Hey naughty girls need love too.
I mean you want to judge
the place
but let's just say a young
Samantha Fox was involved.
Even the covers are hard
core pornography.
This is like Jugs.
You can't say give me the Jugs.
This is why they keep them
in plastic bags usually.
This guy's like-
Do they have to open
a plastic bag?
That place didn't.
Jay knew.
Wait, Ariana Grande's
not on a Club.
Okay, that's
a different magazine.
Club something.
There's different Clubs.
It's Club X.
Oh buddy.
By the way, for the record
before we let you guys go.
I'm gonna go steal
Maureen McCormick's
probably getting the biz
before Eve Plumb
but Eve Plumb's
right in there.
Is she older
than Maureen McCormick?
Like in real life?
I don't know.
And where's Cindy?
I'm an Alice guy.
You've always been an Alice guy.
You held firm on that always.
Dude I told you man,
right now, as a young boy I said
Sam the butcher's
a lucking fucking guy.
She takes care
of the Brady family.
Me and Dan would be a good crush
and push team through the 90s
especially 'cause I'm all Six,
Dan's Blossom.
Oh six.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jennifer von O   thin waist,
big old booty.
I'm Six, you're Blossom.
No, no, no, Dan's coming in
for Blossom
because she has
big Jewish titties.
That's his words.
I'm more Johnny Bravo.
Johnny Bravo?
Yeah, barrel chest, I get it.
Strong forearms.
Strong, strong forearms.
Crashing.
How much did we like Six just
'cause she was named Six though?
Oh it was cool and the hats.
And the hats.